with the mother accused of escaping to
Hawaii as the search for her two missing
children stretches across several states
on Friday she appeared inside an Idaho
courtroom for the first time since their
disappearance and a judge reduced her
bail to 1 million dollars Jonathan
Vigliotti reports in a packed courtroom
Lorie Veloz first appearance back in
Idaho speaking barely above a whisper as
many in the town of Rexburg demanded to
know where our seven-year-old JJ and 17
year old Ty Lee valo who's charged with
felony child abandonment has revealed
nothing about the fate of her kids
investigators confirm Ty Lee was last
seen in Yellowstone National Park there
is no evidence of Ty Lee Ryan leaving
this park the FBI is now calling on
everyone that visited here September 8th
to look through their photos for signs
of the family as Mallos husband Chad de
Belle looked on her defense attorney
complained valo has been hounded by the
masses she cannot go anywhere without
cameras and people scrutinizing her
every single move also speaking out JJ's
grandparents ka-larry Woodcock whose
demand for a welfare tech launched the
search right now I only have one
question where are the kids
where are the kids and bail was set at 1
million dollars if released valo will
have to wear an ankle bracelet at no
point during this hearing did valo or
her attorney mention where the kids are
for CBS this morning Saturday Jonathan
Gotti Rexburg Idaho